it over to another former louisville  cardinals that is time miles radius  sends it home  terry rozier  in the passing lane picked that one off  like a db  wow just running with it  hornets last played on wednesday they  have a full two days off it's an  eternity in the nba  lamelo taps it away from giannis and  we've got another dunk mason public  yeah that's a good start energy wise  gets the crowd involved early  everybody but gordon  has touched the ball probably for the  first time with many  the instincts by lamela you can't teach  that that he's either have it or you  don't  tips that up basically to himself  and then the behind the back pass to  mason who's all along with the reverse  to get things started  40th dunk of the year for mason blumley  and i bet at least 10 of the 40 dunks